you too as in real you you encounter a
boogeyman who is the person in your own
lives that you turn to that you tell
that would believe you and also help you
fight the boogeyman my mom for sure
um my mom and I are all about trust and
she knows me really well and she knows
that it it like she knows when I have
real true honest to God seriousness in
my face and I'm not just making
something up and I think if I really
told her there is a boogeyman in my room
and I'm not kidding I think she would
believe me hmm for me my twin sister
she's just as crazy as I am so she'll go
along with anything I say these are such
beautiful
answers
anything
um I hear Sophie that you're really into
horror movies so I'm curious what kinds
of horror movies do you most like to
watch and then do you find yourself
being drawn to those projects as an
actor as well I feel like this is kind
of just naturally happened because I
started with fairy um genre like I
started with this movie Prospect which
is very sci-fi and people can see that I
can do those like very heightened
circumstances
um I'm open to any genre but then even
just within I went through a huge B
movie phase
um me and Rob bonded over this movie
necromantic and then he got me this post
in necromantic two poster and then I got
my boyfriend a necromantic two puzzle
but a very like I'm just a big
person same with like you like horror
games I love Silent Hill I Love blah
blah blah we can go on is there a dream
horror franchise you would most want to
jump into if you got the opportunity
um maybe I'm trying to think Silent Hill
too
um I'm sure why it's so bad that I'm
like yeah her name but I dressed up as
her for Halloween like three four
Heather Heather Heather Mason Silent
Hill too because everybody would say
that I had the same haircut
now you got a wink at the camera make
sure the producers no they've already
it's already been made
I feel like they are are making another
now that you bring it up I really are
making another Silent Hill movie right
now really yeah I might I might be wrong
I feel like that is in production Vivian
for you and I know you don't love
watching the scary stuff but what is the
scariest movie you've seen thus far I
think I saw the sixth sense I saw the
witches and I saw the mummy you're doing
pretty well in that category yeah this
the scariest ones I've seen uh one I'm
pretty excited to see is the Five Nights
at Freddy's movie which
um oh yeah you play it on your switch uh
I I play it with my dad sometimes on my
PS5 so true I wish I had a PS5 quite
excited for that
so the scares I know aren't as scary
when you are on set actually filming
them so while you're on the set of a
movie like this is there anything in
particular that made you go like I can't
believe that's what it looks like on set
but then it looks like that that's scary
on screen in the finished film The
Boogeyman because like they had this VFX
head that they that they used and like
they would wave it around on a
broomstick like it was scary enough
already but like it's nothing compared
to what the boogeyman actually yeah I
kind of preferred not using it and just
using your imagination same it's like
tennis balls but um but you know it it
like so much more detail in the actual
thing
but
um but uh
yeah
um it was it was really like I was
trying to figure out what it would look
like you know
um and then uh Rob showed me some
concept arts and then he showed me the
3D printed VFX version uh in not a very
subtle way he just waved it around
um until I went what is that and then um
then uh I also some very lovely people
on YouTube have decided to take uh the
jump scares screenshot from the trailer
of The Boogeyman under the bed of course
brighten it brighten it so you can see
it and then put it as the thumbnail of
the trailer they have decided that that
I didn't even notice they did that
that's crazy so uh on YouTube if you
look up the boogeyman trailer you're
going to see him like three down you
know so
um so yeah was there ever an opportunity
to get Rob back and prank him on
sentence scare him
um God I wish I think I might have done
it a few times I feel like you were I
remember I did
um he didn't like I would do like a
creepy doll face and I would just like
watch stuff in my head and I would just
like follow him around with my eyes to
freak out
and I would I would not stop and he
would be like stop it get away from me
so I remember I would do that I like
that I like that you're even so not a
whole lot in these movies keeps me up at
night I can watch anything happen on
screen and sleep easy except anything
that involves teeth and the dentist so
can you tell me a little bit about
shooting the tooth pulling scene
it was long and tedious and this is
gonna sound really cheesy but it was
like pulling teeth wow
um I know yeah that that was that was
bad but um but but yeah it was It was a
long process to film those like three
days of filming that we did and like I I
think it was just a lot of components
because I had to be standing there and
that I had to be sitting in the chair
and then I had to be in bed with her and
then um like what they had me do for the
actual teeth pulls they wanted like the
rest they could just do like see the
tooth or like see my mouth open and then
CGI the tooth in kind of thing but what
they actually did for one shot they did
it for one shot and they had me like
they had it on a piece of floss like a
fake tooth and they had me bite down on
the edge of the floss so it was in my
mouth and then basically they had me uh
they would go three two one and I would
open my mouth and they would pull it so
it looked like the tooth was coming off
oh and then they put black paint on my
tooth to make it look like
tastes like rotten vegetables so yeah
speaking of the technical components so
if I'm curious for you what do you find
more challenging a scare scene where
it's more like a jump scare and you have
to give a really quick reaction or
something that's a little more drawn out
action heavy and has more technical
components in it it can get really
difficult when it's technical but it's
also nice to have a scene that you can
like really build the emotion and not
start from it's hard going into scene
starting from like the most intense
emotion that's where Rob really helped
he would throw books and like throw
books like make noise I would ask for it
I'd be like just scare me
um and it worked and because you can't
just natural I would jump up and down
and
um
yeah I'll wrap with this one because I
heard Rob had told me a bit about an
especially intense scene for you it's
the one in the basement with the with
the mother's dress and the jump scare
there that it was just a very
challenging day on set where you did
that a whole bunch of times that was a
blur I'm curious to hear about that from
your perspective
um I think I mean for that scene it
worked because I was building to
something emotionally and I was really
just thinking as an actor like plotting
all the different
thoughts that she's having so I really
try not to think about the technicality
of it all because that's not my job yeah
I'm an actor
smart way to approach it
you focus on your stuff and you do your
stuff exceptionally well I love this
movie
thank you